The Flash movie has been a magnet for
trouble since the beginning of the DC EU
but James Gunn has some strong words
about the film's quality here's what the
new co-ceo of DC Studios had to say
about it even in the middle of the Slate
of DC Universe announcements James Gunn
and Peter saffron just Unleashed and all
two familiar elephants stood in the room
Ezra Miller's been out of the spotlight
as of late but DC fans have made quite
clear how they feel about the Flash Film
after it stars numerous scandals and
brushes with the lore despite this The
Flash not only perseveres but allegedly
thrives the DC Studios new Big Shots
have had a chance to see DC's upcoming
summer Temple movie and gum was
impressed enough to call it one of the
best superhero movies he's seen during
his DC announcements he said the flash
is amazing like truly is one of the best
superhero movies I've ever seen Andy
musketti did an amazing job and I'm
really excited for everybody to see her
saffron also noted that Mel does
currently committed to recovery and
their DCU future will be discussed at an
appropriate Point down the line it's
easy to wonder why in a world where
pretty much every other aspect of the
DCU is getting a complete reboot the
flash is still around drawing praise and
inching toward his June Premiere after
all the movie's been a magnet for
trouble even without Miller's own
significant additions to the controversy
pile dce used the flash has been played
by more than a share of more
conventional hassles like changing
directors terrible delay news and the
like yet through all of its woes The
Flash has managed to avoid becoming
Radioactive in the Studio's eyes to the
point that the new studio heads seemed
to be just as happy with the beleaguered
movie as those who came before what on
Earth could cause this seemingly
inflappable Goodwill toward a project
that when you view it from the outside
should buy All rights have had a massive
ax of ring above it for a long time now
there are several likely reasons for gun
and sufferings pro The Flash attitude
despite all the controversies
surrounding Miller let's take take a
look at them first of the reasons may
very well be the simplest of all money
per The Hollywood Reporter The Flash is
a 200 million dollar movie and therefore
significantly more difficult to flesh
away than something like Batgirl which
had a budget of around 90 million
dollars and as DC Studios Executives gun
and saffron simply can't bad-mouth The
Flash regardless of their personal
feelings though that's not to say
they're not telling the truth when they
say it's great the flash a fantastic
movie that I really love that resets the
entire DC Universe people who have
actually seen the flash seem to love it
and praise it to High Heavens especially
if they're personally invested in the
film succeeding that includes Warner
Brothers Discovery CEO David zazlov who
had great things to say about the Flash
in a 2022 earnings call Earth's variety
reported he was talking about three
upcoming DC movies when he said we've
seen them we think they're terrific and
we think we can make them even better of
course it's worth noting that one of
them was Black Adam so your mileage may
vary still while Miller's past Behavior
may very well warrant a hole for the
cervical discussion about the merits of
separating art from the artist there's a
very decent chance that the flash will
turn out to be a worthy swan song for
the old DC EU as for Miller well even if
you're willing to disregard their
various issues the fact remains that
they're one of the last Justice League
guards Still Standing even if the flash
makes Avatar the way of water money at
the box office there's a chance that gun
and saffron are simply waiting for
Miller to recover and recuperate in
peace before sitting down to have a
conversation that ends the same way it
did for Henry Cavill and Gal Gadot
[Music]
foreign